these have been another phenomenal games
for paralympics gb with more than a
hundred medals now won
hannah coccraft smashed her own record
as she took gold in the t-34 800 meters
final that's her seventh paralympic
title i think i was not 0.12 of a second
away from my own world record and to do
that would have been immense but all in
all i got the gold medal and that's all
it's about so i can't complain too much
alex sean davies won a third gold medal
in the f-63 shot putt
and charlotte henshaw triumph in the kl2
200 meters para canoe
so three more gold medals on the
penultimate day in japan
london 2012 was a game changer for the
paralympic movement in this country so
it was fitting that athletes gathered
here in the olympic park for an event
aimed at inspiring the next generation
all around there were stories of
incredible human resilience ellen
buttrick was diagnosed with a
degenerative eye condition that robbed
her of her sight at the age of 19. she
decided to compete as a paralympian and
took gold in tokyo
it was a phenomenal experience actually
to be out there and to
be there with the team to be part of
such a large motorsport team and then
i was worried when we got that people
wouldn't be very welcoming but the
japanese public just like embraced us so
much we had people with gb flags waving
us every time we went anywhere on the
minibus and yeah and it was just amazing
to get out there
ben pritchard was left paralyzed after a
freak cycling accident in 2016 so he
decided to take up rowing and represent
his country at the paralympics what was
tokyo like it was incredible you know
and yeah whilst i'm still very raw about
my fifth place the whole experience of
going out to tokyo being part of a
multi-sport team was just breathtaking
you know we were just talking earlier
about how much we are all sports fans
and you know you rock up to the airport
and david wheeler's on your flight you
know you sit next to ellie robinson at
dinner and it's just as a sports one
that was
amazing and then you have the whole
thing of you are now a paralympian and
that was pretty special you know whilst
i didn't get a medal i did come away
with a paralympic record so that's
pretty pretty cool and
ellie robinson won gold in rio but could
only manage fifth place in japan
everyone's been through quite a lot in
the past year with the pandemic
there's been so much uncertainty and
it's felt very much out of our control
so i wanted to remind people that they
are more powerful than anything that
threatens to weaken them
there is just one more day left for a
paralympics gb to add to its medal tally
for the athletes who are already home
it's time to rest recover
and start planning for paris 2024 and
the brady sky news in east london